a aterosclerose é uma doença
potencialmente fatal que pode começar a
se desenvolver durante a infância esta
doença é um processo em que os depósitos
de gordura chamados de placas se
acumulam nas paredes internas das
artérias reduzindo ou bloqueando com
completamente o fluxo sanguíneo embora
as causas exatas da aterosclerose não
sejam Claras muitos cientistas acreditam
que ela começa com lesões na parede
interna das artérias chamada endotélio
as substâncias transportadas pelo sangue
como colesterol gordura e resíduos
celulares se acumulam na área danificada
da parede arterial as reações químicas
que ocorrem dentro do acúmulo de
material fazem com que asol moléculas de
colesterol se oxidem isso resulta em uma
resposta inflamatória na qual as células
endoteliais nos locais danificados
liberam substâncias químicas que indicam
um pedido de ajuda em resposta os
monócitos da corrente sanguínea são
direcionados para o local danificado o
estímulo de colesterol oxidado converte
os monóxidos em macrófagos os macrófagos
comem e digerem as moléculas de
colesterol como resultado deste processo
os macrófagos se transformam em células
espumosas que se acumulam para formar a
placa conforme a placa aumenta de
tamanho a parede arterial fica mais
grossa e
endurece ao mesmo tempo as células
musculares lisas na parede arterial
começam a se
multiplicar
a maioria das células musculares Lisa se
move em direção à superfície da placa
essas células contribuem para a formação
de uma capa fibrosa firme que cobre a
placa finalmente a passagem através da
artéria se Estreita o suficiente para
reduzir o fluxo sanguíneo e a quantidade
de oxigênio recebido pelos órgãos que
fornece com o tempo a capa pode corroer
e se abrir liberando a placa na corrente
sanguínea a placa pode fluir e
contribuir para a formação de um coágulo
que pode interromper o fluxo de sangue
como resultado um fornecimento limitado
de sangue está disponível nas áreas ao
redor da artéria parcialmente obstruída
degradando e potencialmente matando os
tecidos
vizinhos